the anger that we are carrying
collectively
is deep down it's a it's an anger of
despair it's an anger of
of hopelessness it's it's an anger of
powerlessness in
in where are we going as society what's
happening
with our politicians what's what's
happening at the collective levels
what's happening with our societies we
feel so
powerless to what is really happening in
the world
that anger is building up and i think
it's it
that's happening as we're speaking it's
building up collectively
and when i say we're not heading in the
right direction it's because i think
that that anger
will begin to erupt
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantine kissin and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
our brilliant guest today is a
psychotherapist dr luiz mazzanti welcome
to trigonometry
thank you so much it's so good to have
you on the show
uh for anyone who isn't familiar with
you or your work i'll just say that we
came across you first
watching uh david fuller's documentary a
glitch in the matrix in which you
he asked you a lot about the kathy
newman interview with jordan peterson
and we just thought oh wow what an
interesting perspective would really
need to get into some of this
but beyond that for anyone who's not
familiar with you or your work
tell everybody who are you how are you
where you are what has been the journey
that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us
oh wow that's a big question yeah i
think
maybe um around 10
12 years ago i was at the height of my
academic career
and i'd been working really really hard
to get to where i was
and i kind of achieved everything i
could in my field
and i was mid 30s and i realized
what am i doing i'm i'm not happy i
don't know who i am as a woman
i don't know who's inside my body i
don't know my sexuality i don't know my
spirituality i don't know all the things
that i
i kind of had to compromise in order to
to perform in academia
so that sent me on a really big journey
into
going to the deeper side the mystical
sides of life and and
i discovered psychospiritual
psychotherapy which i studied
psychosynthesis and i i started to
become a psychotherapist in
in that area and it was a deep
personal and spiritual journey that
really took me into who am i as a human
being and why am i here
and beginning to understand the deep
experience of being a woman the deep
experience of being a mother
the deep experience of having a body and
and what does that mean
and that kind of took me into
what is most meaningful in life
experience this is really about
what i've been investigating ever since
in myself and
in the clients that i work with now and
and the people that i train
is how can we go deep in our human
experience
as men as women in these bodies and
and as everything in between wherever we
find ourselves in this human experience
what does it mean so i think i i started
with that
curiosity when i came out of my academic
mind
what else is here when i stop thinking
all the time and start
feeling with my body with my intuition
what else is available
and and that that kind of took me took
me here where i'm working with people to
come home to themselves in their bodies
and and have that deep experience
of of the human journey um
yeah i think it's fascinating it's
fascinating what you're talking about
because
i think the the connection with your
body is one thing that in one society we
don't really
deal with or talk about it you don't get
to you don't go to school to be taught
about that right no one tells you about
that
and also you know you talk about your
experience getting to your mid-30s being
successful in your career but then
suddenly realizing you're not happy well
it's sort of a single
example of something happening at a
broader level of society where
we've seen for 70 odd years women's
happiness in particular plummeting but
also men's too
and you know mental ill health on the
rise as well
what are your thoughts on the sort of
like why is that all happening what are
the
the the areas where we're becoming more
and more disconnected from the things
that we ought to be connected to
i think we've we've lost touch really
with
the meaning of why we're here the
meaning of
what is this human experience we're just
producing and producing and producing
kind of just
keeping the wheel going and we're
realizing as we're doing
that it doesn't give us anything other
than survival in the moment and maybe
but it boosts our ego a little bit
sometimes it it it hurts our ego
it's kind of that dance of of the ego
and at some point that becomes
exhausting
when we realize it's not just all about
me and my personal experience
what more is here and i think people are
really disconnected from from that level
when we are in the wheel
at the same time as deep inside we know
that this is not sustainable where we
are going as society where we are going
as humankind it's not sustainable so
we are kind of we're we're keeping we're
keeping an identity
going and we know it's not true and i
think
that in a compromise is what what is
tearing people down the knowing that
something more true is calling
and we're just not listening and why is
this way that we're living
not sustainable wha what do you mean by
that the effect that we're having on our
pla
on the planet the effect that we're
having on our bodies what do you mean by
sustainable
first of all it's not sustainable on our
planet we see that
we see that very clearly that that we
are getting out of sync
with ecology with too many people on the
planet we can see that that's just a
very basic fact
we can see that it's not sustainable in
the long run
we are out of touch with what really
makes us happy
that's another thing it's it's we're
just spinning in the wheel of thinking
we have to do something
it's not sustainable either and we know
that that it's overpopulated we
the climate is changing it's not
sustainable
within a very few couple of years we'll
begin to see
more and more tangible effects
of things that we are not taking
seriously our economy
will probably be crashing our societies
are not sustainable they're not they're
not stable
there's a lot of tension in our
societies that is
just bubbling under the surface and
right now
we are able to keep it kind of safe and
contained
but i don't think that's going to last
forever because there is
in the individuals and in the collective
there is this this knowing that
this is not the right direction what are
we doing
and you talk about the right about the
right direction what is the right
direction louise for you
yeah that's a very good question
i think the right direction is really to
to pause
and to stop producing all the time and
to start feeling
it's in a way it's it's a i took the
microcosm of that in my own life that i
i
stopped performing in that big way
and said i really don't know what is the
direction right now i pulled every block
in my life
literally to the point where there was
nothing left of my old identity
and i think as a society we need to do
this journey
in finding new values finding what is
life really about what has value to us
how are we connecting with each other
what is what is life this miracle of
being alive in our body
of being able to breathe in a body to
see smell
touch and feel that is an incredibly
deep journey
that we're not honoring right now as
we're just racing ahead our nervous
system
are constantly on high alert and we're
not feeling we're not really being
present with
the the miracle it is to actually be
here in this human experience
and louise one of the things that i you
know i've done some of the sort of work
that you're talking about in my own life
you know personal development and
training and all that sort of thing and
i found it very useful
but one of the things that inevitably
comes out of what you're saying is
the more you connect with your body the
more the male
and female aspects of this start to come
in
because our bodies are different our
hormonal makeup is different
and i i don't know whether you'd agree
with this but i think
it has been the case that we in the last
many decades have sort of tried to erase
all of them pretend that
actually you know we're not men and
women actually you know like we're kind
of the same like you know we can all do
the same stuff we all think the same we
all
you know it's it's all sort of you know
it's up for grabs
we it's it's a socially negotiated thing
and you can just be who you are without
ever having to deal with the fact that
biologically
you are of a particular sex and it's i
don't know
because i don't know exactly the nature
of your work but i imagine you might
have some thoughts on that
yeah it's i love this question
because it it everything is in that
question because
what you're saying logically makes sense
of course post-modernism
deconstructivism
makes sense like we have to go through
that stage where we question all these
essential truths but once we've done
that
what is left when we stop thinking about
it when we stop
thinking the world from a conceptual
level and we start feeling
when we start slowing down so we can
actually feel
what is this human experience about in
me
at an experiential level we start
connecting with something that's deeper
than the conceptual constructions of of
values in society we start feeling
our existential condition and in that
existential condition
i don't think we can just say there is
nothing like a man
or a woman or the masculine and the
feminine from a felt perspective
of course we have both insiders
absolutely
and also some people find themselves on
different spectres of that
but we have male bodies we have female
bodies
and that's a given that we have to
somehow
make peace with unless we want to change
but
it is it is a condition that we have
and that does not mean that we identify
as
a woman or a man as society has
conditioned us
absolutely i i really agree with those
questions
are so important to ask we have to move
through this
phase absolutely those stereotypical
images of what it is to be a man and a
woman
they don't work anymore but once we've
done that
that's the next level and that level is
about really feeling
what is in in lack of better words what
is the feminine in me
what is a masculine in me how does it
want to express what does it feel like
as an archetype as as as an energy
and some people are more connected to
the masculine energy some people are
more connected to the feminine energy
most of these people will be women and
men and of course
we oscillate all the time but we can't
say that that they don't exist
they exist in my experience as simply
existential
polarities that are within us and
between us
and and they want different things they
have different qualities
and a thing that i i am really
interested in
in is how that shows up in society how
that shows up in the
in the discussions we have in society
about men
and about women and about that really
really
hot space between men and women and i
say hot space because it's both a space
it's a space where there's a lot of
passion and
there's a lot of excitement and there's
also a lot of very very difficult
emotions
and what what's that about what are
these emotions and why
why are they so hot right now
the emotions are basically because we're
moving now we've been moving out for a
very long time but we are still
in that transitional phase of moving out
of
a society that was structured around
patriarchal values that's
that's a given that's that how it's been
for a very very long time
and for a long time we've also we've
been rebelling against
it we've been we've been we've been
moving through that paradigm
but again with this paradigm i think we
have to be careful that we don't
throw out the baby with the bath water
because
as an existential given
as human beings we're vulnerable we're
vulnerable because we are live in a body
that makes us very very vulnerable we're
physically vulnerable
we are emotionally vulnerable and what
we do
is we try to reach out
to someone that can protect us that's
bigger and stronger than we are
that's what we're primed to do
and men have had that ability to be the
bigger and stronger
that women were reaching out to for
safety
that's how it's been for a very very
long time
and now that paradigm has has been
moving for a long time it's beginning to
shift
and right now women are not happy with
that role
and and they're angry about it they're
angry about the shadow sides of that
role which has been
the misuse the abuse of power
but what i see is that that discussion
happens without looking at nothing
exists
in a void the masculine
abuse of power does not exist in a void
why why is that the masculine also
exists with a feminine that has been
adding
into into that dynamic and i looking at
that dynamic is
really important for me in in my work
where i work with a lot
mostly i work with a lot of female
clients that have a difficult
relationship with being a woman
and have a difficult relationship with
their sexuality
and have difficult relationships with
the masculine whether they are
wanting to be in relationship with men
or with women
but that space is difficult because they
don't know
where to put the masculine they don't
know what to do with it
they don't know what is a masculine
about is it wanting to overpower me or
is it not worth anything has it lost the
blood
and i think many women are struggling
with that whole
what is the masculine when it's not
patriarchy and
do you think louise part of the problem
is is that the role of men has changed
in society whereby
before you know there was a very
traditional structure the male was a
breadwinner went out to work
the woman was a homemaker now because of
marriage of different reasons
that is no longer applicable do you
think that's part of the reason why
we're in crisis
i think that's a very big part of it i
think men
have in their own journey men have lost
their identity
and women are reacting to that so women
are both angry
and and women are also feeling more
empowered like that kind of
that tower of patriarchy is crumbling
so women are reacting to that in
different ways and men are also reacting
to it men are reacting with
i don't know how how to be a man anymore
i don't have any role models
men have to make it up as as they go
along now
and they have all these reactions from
women
to deal with these reactions these
projections and they're very strong
still we're still only on our way out of
that paradigm
and and to see from my perspective as a
woman working with women to see what
women do to men
and see the suffering that i'm going to
say we
inflict on men is painful
and it's what do you mean what are you
talking about when you say the suffering
you
women as a whole inflict on men as a
whole what do you mean
i mean that many men
now don't really know how to be
with women they don't know where women
are with men
they don't know can i be myself can i be
in my power can i just be
my spontaneous natural expression oh am
i gonna offend anyone
am i gonna what's gonna happen if i just
express this men
are really tiptoeing around women as it
is right now
and women are still waiting
to see if this kind of overpowering is
going to happen women are still
on alert for that energy and men
get anxious around women and that space
means that
none of us are able to actually relate
to each other we still
we're still in the projections that that
belong to the pastor projections are not
true anymore
but we're still we're still carrying
that energy so we're not actually able
to
see who we are what we're bringing to
the table
each of us we're not able to see each
other in a clear light and i i
see that in women what they see in men
is still this waiting there's still this
rage that's waiting to come out
that's that that work hasn't fully
completed yet
and men are just there waiting to see
when is it gonna
come my way when is it going to happen
so
none of us are really using our ability
to actually be in synergy to co-create
to
to to add different different energies
to the whole
and still i think that's a part of the
crisis that is in the world
right still that we are not
we're not co-creating we're not feeding
each other we're not
we're not using each other's sensitivity
each other's abilities each other's
gifts
we're more we're we're still we're still
fighting them
and you say that we're still fighting do
you think as well part of the problem is
our understanding of sex and
relationships has been so
distorted by pornography that in a way
we we find it impossible to connect in a
way that is real
because we see sex and connection as a
type of performance almost
i think porn has has a lot to answer for
in in that regard that it had made has
made this kind of
stereotypical
difference between men and women has
made it very clear it's both diminished
men and it's diminished women so
we have the kind of the role models for
our real power for our real potency the
role models that we have
are really really poor they are
degenerated they are kind of the shadow
sides
of who we really are and i think we as
we are seeing
a consequence of this because we know
porn is not real
but it still creeps into our
subconscious that we think we have to be
like that
to be in our power to be in our potency
and and that's that becomes very
distorted that easily becomes distorted
because it's still
it's still working our subconscious
earlier you were talking about the
post-modernist approach
and this is what i was saying it's very
popular to rail against post-modernist
ways of thinking now and
and i do to a very large extent because
i think there are a lot of flaws in that
approach but having said that that you
have to also concede that there they're
elements of truth
for example the idea of how men and
women
should necessarily dress right now i
still have like an instinctive
discomfort if i'm being honest with the
idea of like men wearing skirts for
example right
but but i also recognize that that
instinctive discomfort
is a product of socialization right
there's no
god-given biological reason that men and
women should dress in this particular
way
and so the idea that some aspects of our
behavior are socially constructed
is a fact right and you're talking about
how well
you know some elements of that social
construction
were about maintaining what was then
accurately in my view could be described
as the patriarchy right
men behave like this women to hail like
this and men seem to end up in all the
roles of power and influence and
whatever
for the most part and now we've as you
were talking about we've
gradually gone to strip that away
uh and i i think it's left
both sexes quite
discombobulated and uncertain about what
they're supposed to do
and and i see that in you know in in my
own relationships and relationships with
people around me
like men's men still know that a woman
does want a confident strong man
but at the same time being strong and
confident is sort of like are you are
you supposed to be that still
and women are the same are you supposed
to like that or are you supposed to be
repelled by that we're sort of in this
limbo aren't we yeah
yeah i'm all for that
post-modernism that opened
opened our minds that that that
destroyed those
rigid paradigms absolutely
so important the problem with
post-modernism is that it easily stays
as a mental construct
so we think how am i supposed to be
instead of feeling and i really will
come back to
that sense of feeling because it has to
emerge from inside we have to feel
the masculine inside and the feminine
inside and we have to be able
to not get stuck in one so
i have a male body or i have a female
body it must mean blah blah blah
but let it come from a felt experience
what does that mean to me
today i mean my masculine tomorrow i'm
in my feminine or it shifts from moment
to moment
and also in our relationships can we can
we switch roles
can we be the one that takes initiative
can we be the breadwinner
can we can we oscillate between those
energies in ourselves
and in our relationship and one day i
want to dress like this one day i want
to dress like that
but not because i think that i should be
doing that because that's the right
paradigm
but because it feels true when i connect
to myself
this is how i want to express today
tomorrow i might want to express in a
different way
and there's still a lot of work to do in
having the courage to do what feels
right
but i think we have to be careful with
thinking what's right and and my sense
is that a lot
of this as it is right now
comes from a comes from a mental
conceptual place it makes sense and and
i think it's important that it happens
but it's not the truth we are
experimenting with with a conceptual
paradigm
great but we're still evolving we're
still in a process
and i think that's that's a very good
point that we are still in a process
because if you saw what happened
with me too it was very important
because it had women to talk
about their experiences but at the same
time there was a
an anger that was unleashed at the same
time
and do you think that's part of the
process of healing
or do you think that was something else
i think it was a it was important step
that anger was a long long long held
anger
and some of it was a righteous anger and
some of it was an anger that had gone
into its own spin
but the process of going through it
of acknowledging in in ourselves in the
collective
and being acknowledged having that
acknowledged
i think it's extremely important that
that happened
but let us not get stuck in oh
now we reached kind of the truth this is
how society should be this is the truth
about women this is the truth about men
and and women are allowed to always be
angry and we should be watching each
other all the time
that is really it's a really deep
misunderstanding that that is leading us
astray
if we keep watching each other with that
suspicion
that it happened was was important and i
i think there was also some
there's been some victims in that on
both sides i think that's important to
acknowledge
men has also suffered
and in the in the documentary that i
talked about earlier
you were talking specifically about the
interview between
kathryn newman and jordan peterson and
you talked about and i'm paraphrasing
from memory and
for you it's a couple of years ago as
well so correct me if i'm wrong in any
way when i
try and recollect exactly what you said
but something along the lines of
the rage that you could see in kathy
newman's behavior
is a rage that any woman can
connect and to and feel if she so
chooses
yeah right is that and so
is it really is what's happening in
modern society like we all have a reason
to be angry and increasingly we're
starting to choose to connect to that
anger
i honestly have a sense that we will see
more and more anger
more and more anger coming out now women
have been really erring their anger
some as i said righteous anger and some
of it not so much
and men are also beginning there's riots
going on
and that anger maybe has a different
source but i but i think that the anger
that we are carrying collectively
is deep down it's a it's an anger of
despair it's an anger of
of hopelessness it's it's an anger of
powerlessness in in
where are we going as society what's
happening with our politicians
what's what's happening at the
collective levels what's happening with
our societies
we feel so powerless to what is really
happening in the world
that anger is building up and i think
it's it
that's happening as we're speaking it's
building up collectively
and when i say we're not heading in the
right direction it's because i think
that that anger
will begin to erupt because we're aware
like
what what are we doing also how we
treating animals it's it's a different
thing but how we
treating animals at some point in the
future we'll look back and say
oh my god how come that people did that
that was really
that was really something and there's so
many of these things that we will look
back and say
how come that we were so unevolved and
that knowing inside that's roaring
that's rawing in all of us we just don't
really know what to do with it so we
burn cars or we smash the police or
whatever
wherever it starts but that anger i
think it's
it's it's an anger that that all of us
have in
in the powerlessness of
covet is just a little kind of a little
reminder of we are very vulnerable as a
society and we are very vulnerable
as people we are very vulnerable as
communities
we are very vulnerable to to things that
happened like feels
this is just covered that we no one kind
of created it
but how do our politicians deal with
that what's really happening
we're powerless and we're powerless and
we don't know we really don't know
anything to be honest we can
have a lot of theories about
this and that but we don't really know
what is real we have so many stats we
have so many experts that are saying
this and that
we don't know how to sieve in it most
people feel feel overpowered
by by life and i think that creates
a rage of hopelessness that will begin
to erupt more and more
do you think part of the problem louise
especially when you look at covert
is in the west death is a taboo subject
we don't talk about death we don't
acknowledge it
we seem to we seem to have bought into
this idea that actually we're going to
live forever and you can see it you know
yeah exactly uh much to the chagrin of
everyone around you
but um but you see it also you know in
the smooth
blank expressionless faces of our
celebrities who don't want to
just don't want to admit that the age
that they really are
isn't part of the fury and the rage from
covid
the realization and you talk about it
yourself that we are fragile
but more importantly we're mortal yeah
as i said we are vulnerable just because
we are alive
it's scary if we really connect with it
the price of admission to be alive
is we have to die and we're vulnerable
all the way through at all stages of
life we're vulnerable
that's scary and we don't know we don't
know what to do with that existential
vulnerability
and we don't know as you say we don't
know how to talk about that
we don't know how to talk about yeah at
some point it ends
that's this this life is um
it's a scary place and and how do we
how do we start to as individuals
because i i get this very strong sense
from what you're talking about that
the solution to all of this comes at the
level of the individual
it's by individuals thinking not
thinking but
slowing down feeling what is right for
them and and
changing their own thought patterns and
behavior and
and how they feel about things i've been
struck by a thing
this is turning into personal therapy
now but do you want me to go
yeah yeah thanks mate just uh i'll i'll
lie on this little
sofa and talk to to louise but uh what
i've been noticing is during this whole
pandemic and lockdown i'm i'm very
concerned about some of the
the ways we've dealt with the pandemic i
think they've been
excessive unnecessary in many things and
and panic
driven more than anything but it doesn't
really matter how you feel about it
what i've been struck by is in my own my
life is great like
the lockdown in many ways meant that i
spend more time with my wife
i have a job that i love doing this you
know i'm surrounded by friends like my
life is good
so i feel good about me but i also feel
very concerned about what's happening in
society and sort of like
weaving those two things together
there's a big clash going on i think
quite a lot of people feel that way at
the moment that maybe their own life
isn't really that bad
but what seems to be happening around us
as you say there's a repressed thing
that we're all
we're all realizing that our lives could
be changed
like that by people who we have no
no no ability to influence at all
how does how does one reconcile those
two things
yeah that's a
that's the journey how do we reconcile
that we stay right in
we stay right in there right right
inside
that question that is
how do i contain my own human experience
how do i make peace with
the price of this admission is i have to
feel all these things
i don't know what to do with all these
feelings they're here
can i contain them and stay present stay
with a light of awareness on stay awake
to wow what a ride this journey this
this human life is
i don't know how it's gonna end and i
don't know what it means
and and it's vulnerable and i feel
powerless
but i'm here and one of the things that
that
for me the pandemic pandemic is really
broad
when we're so physically disconnected is
that
we can connect in different ways we can
connect on the screen and we can connect
with our consciousness and i think
this is now i said a lot of things that
that that sound
quite pessimistic but i also
feel that there's a paradigm that's
beginning to emerge where we feel our
consciousness is more and more connected
because it's not just about me and my
personal experience and me slowing down
it means when i slow down and i begin to
feel
life in myself not concepts and ideas
but the felt sense experience and i
connect
with other people when i i'm in this
place
we're beginning to feel more and more
that
i feel your experience i don't have
to physically be with you i can just
listen to the sound of your voice i can
listen to the vibration of the sound
and i can feel i can feel like we are
beginning to be one consciousness more
and more
and that's something that is beginning
to emerge that hasn't fully shown itself
but that feeling we are not that
different that's another thing we're not
that different we think we are so unique
in our experience and
and all that we're not that different we
are wired mostly exactly in the same way
we are so predictable as human beings so
what i am experiencing
is that it's very easy to tap into and
influence each other
we don't need to be physically connected
in order to
to create a field of consciousness where
what i feel
becomes what you feel and we can begin
to change
things like that i'm very
excited and very interested in what does
it mean
when we use our consciousness i want to
say as a technology it's
it's it's not a tangible technology but
it is a technology
because it is a way it creates we become
a bigger neural network
that has a lot of potential it's not
that i that i have the answer of where
this is going but
we are beginning to create to create
those connections of becoming a bigger
neural network
and i think that will hold a lot of
positive change a lot of really
interesting new narrative
about what does it mean to be a human
being and we haven't discovered that
we're beginning to
but it's way more than these boxes that
we have placed ourselves in as it is now
do you think part of the thing that
might actually help and i this is what
happened to me during corona so i was a
stand-up comedian
i was gigging every night of the week i
was doing you know well i was earning
money
most money that i've ever earned and
then all of a sudden
overnight it stopped
and i was left alone in my flat
overnight everything i worked for
stopped and then you suddenly realize
that these things these ideas that
you've been chasing
there are many ways an illusion they
don't matter what matters is the
connections that you have with other
people
do you think we may have been reminded
of that and we may appreciate that far
more when
all these lockdowns are over we're able
to socialize again and we're able to see
our family again
i think it's what's happened is a
massive shift in our values of course
because
most of us have been as you say we've
simply been slammed out
of our identity of our identifications
this is who i thought myself to be
it's not possible anymore so who am i
and what really matters when i'm sat
there in my flat dead board
and physically on my own what am i going
to do what really matters
and that takes us into that fields of
consciousness where it really is about
connection
it is about what can we create when we
come together
what can we create when we feel each
other when we are on a human journey not
just
all about our identity and what am i
doing what are you doing in life which
kind of
identification game are we playing out
but who are we as human beings i think
that that is
also a shift in our values that that is
happening and i really like
the fact that we are so much online and
and and sometimes you're in a studio
sometimes you're in your home
and we are seeing more and more of each
other we're beginning to unpeel a bit
more
show a bit more it's not all shiny
it becomes more and more real and that
ironically happens when the world
becomes virtual i think there's a very
interesting
dichotomy in in in in that kind of
collective intimacy that we are also
able to create
that wasn't possible in the same way
before
that's really interesting liz i want to
talk briefly about something else you
talked about
the fact that there's a bubbling rage
fueled by our hopelessness and
powerlessness that we feel
what about fear because one of the
things that has
absolutely shocked me during the
pandemic particularly
is how willing people have been to
give up certain rights certain freedoms
that we all used to take for granted and
assume
could not be those we assumed they were
inalienable from us the
the the right to walk on the street to
go for a jog
to to meet friends to eat in a
restaurant all of these things have gone
like that
and the support seemingly at least we're
told by pollsters is
you know the vast majority of the public
are very happy with this and they want
more of it
and i i've personally maybe i'm just
quite a risk
hungry person i've never had an issue
with taking risks
but a lot of people seem to have turned
out
to my surprise and it could just be my
ignorance but a lot of people surprised
me by how risk-averse they were
in the middle of this do you have any
insights on on why that might have
happened if you share my analysis
yeah yeah honestly i think we are in a
collective trauma
we are in a collective we are both we we
are both at the same time we are in a
collapse
we are just collapsed in hopelessness we
don't know we really we feel
disempowered we don't actually really
know what to do
and there's so much going on exactly
with feeling overpowered
what's going on politically how is that
suddenly possible
are we becoming a police state what's
really happening
so there's a collapse so that's one
that's one trauma
response another trauma response is
dissociation
we also dissociated we're detached we
just got
into let's have intellectual
conversations or let's watch a lot of tv
or let's just veg out and not think
about it
that's dissociation and and
both the collapse and the dissociation
happens when our system is in overwhelm
when we simply can't compute what's
happening
and i think collectively we can't
compute what's happening because
we don't know it's not over yet
and and covid is just it that's that's
just that's just a little circle that
kind of tickles us in
hey people life life is beginning to
change wake up
wake up and right now i think we are in
in freeze and in detach
collectively and at some point and this
is where when i'm talking about the
collective
neural network that is also forming
that that comes more online when we
begin to unfreeze from that place and
realize
okay but there's other possibilities
there's other ways we can connect
there's other ways to find meaning
there's other ways to be human but right
now we are going through
a state of trauma because everything we
thought that was okay this is just how
it's gonna be
is not it's not possible it's not
possible right now
and when it becomes possible again the
world will have changed it's happening
kind of
mostly under the radar but it's
happening at very deep levels
and louise do you do you think another
part of the problem is
and let's talk about politics briefly so
you know trump was elected and then
biden was elected and everybody sort of
went well you know
everything's fine again now are we not
learning
from our mistakes meaning that we
continue to make the same mistake again
and again
well electing old white men yeah exactly
but
but in a sense you know i mean
collectively we're making these mistakes
again and again whether it's with the
institutions whether it's with the
political system
whether it's with our treatment of the
planet whatever it may be
yeah i really don't know what to say to
that
because there is a big problem
around our political structures our
political systems it's very obvious they
don't work
but it's not like we have a better
answer okay we're just gonna
do this instead we don't know how we're
gonna sort that out
i don't know what to say to that but i
can
see that it is an incredibly big
big problem that we have such i'm gonna
say degenerated leadership
because i i didn't grow up in england
but something that i really really love
about that country
is the myth of king arthur arthur
where i love the english countryside and
i
i love there's a lot of that mysticism
and i think that that myth is a part of
it
where they say the king is a land
and let's just say the king or the queen
is the land
which means that leadership is not about
power over
leadership is about being it's about
serving the well-being there is no
leader without
the land the land is the leader
and we've completely forgotten that
leadership is
degenerated and self-interested it's not
really about the land
how it's become tyranny so this is what
jordan peterson often talks about we've
gone from
a powerful but benevolent leadership
that looks out for the interests of the
people to
corrupt tyrannical leadership that only
looks out for the interest of itself
yeah yeah yeah how do we change that
system how do we put a better system in
place
that's a very difficult question but
revolution
yeah that probably isn't a pretty answer
that's the truth to the difficult
questions there isn't a pretty answer
yeah yeah louise uh we've got about 10
minutes there's one thing i wanted to
come back to which is the men and women
thing and my wife
uh will be very uh unhappy with me if i
don't bring this up because
what i've what we've noticed and i think
a lot of people have noticed and you
talked about at the beginning of our
interviews
the more you connect with who you
actually are you slow down and you
notice
not what you're supposed to feel not
what you've been
told that you're supposed to feel but
actually how you feel
it's difficult to not then notice well
as a man there's certain things that
drive me in this direction
and it's only when you fully connect
with that that i feel for myself i'm
able
to connect with the feminine parts of me
to to be more
you know gentle or diplomatic or
whatever the stereotypes you want to put
on it
and one of the things my wife has been
talking to me is the importance of the
the cycle
and recognizing things that come with
that uh and that's you know a taboo
subject for
you know for a hundred different reasons
but men also have a cycle too
you're just you're just constantly
depressed and angry
like but we all have like patterns
that that that that we go through
what advice do you or would you give to
both men and women in terms of being
aware of that being present to that
uh and and you know i just increasingly
am aware that's not something you can
pretend away from the human experience
right if your body is flushed with a
certain types of hormones
for both men and women you can't ignore
that right so what do we do about that
light of consciousness really be aware
[Music]
this is how i'm feeling right now i'm
flooded with this feeling
feel it really be fully in the feeling
let the feminine
inside show you here the feminine is
full of feeling the feminine is always
looking out for the tribe the feminine
is feeling how is the field
light of consciousness there's a field
here wow this field is
feeling a lot and light of awareness in
there is a field that's feeling a lot
what are we going when we stay in our
inner alignment
what is the choice we're gonna make what
are we gonna do with that feeling again
the king of the queen is a land the land
is a feeling
what are we what is the decision we're
gonna make how are we gonna be with that
feeling
what does that feeling want how does it
want to express
and how do we with our structured mind
with our masculine how do we want to
conduct the feeling
it really is about that inner alchemy
it's about bridging the masculine and
the feminine inside
and when we are flushed listening to
life is expressing something
and having the light of awareness to not
just in in
in pure feeling act out
but saying i i'm gonna i'm gonna listen
to what this feeling is telling me
so it's neither black or white like i'm
wearing it's neither black or white it
really is to stay right in the middle
and feel both
and we tend to want to dismiss one or
the other
yes we do but isn't part of the
challenge as well that a lot of us live
in these you know
city landscapes where it almost seems
designed
for you to not experience stillness to
for you to not experience that feeling
because it's a constantly sensing
sensory overload because you're go go
go go go so actually you never get to
experience that stillness
and in many ways when you do you're sort
of bereft because you're missing that
constant stimulation
i think it's it's a good point
and i think we are always in choice in
every moment we enjoy
you don't have to be like on a
meditation retreat out in nature before
you can sit still and begin to feel
in every moment in this moment the
feeling is
is available right now just slow down
and feel
it's not complicated it's not like you
need to design your whole life around it
or you can't live a normal life you
can't have a job you can't be in a
society
that's again that's again black and
white a misunderstanding
that being able to connect with the
field
is always available we have a body
we have feelings we have we have our
breath we can
feel every time we tune in it's never
further away than that
tune in there's a breath how am i
feeling
and yes there's a screen there's people
i have to talk to there's phones ringing
there's whatever there is
and i'm here it's it's that simple and
that hard
yeah it's it's really interesting to me
that
whenever we've had this conversation
whether that's with you
or with jordan hall or with jordan
peterson
whenever we we pose these questions
about society
the answer always comes back down to the
level of the individual which is it's
you
that has to you know in jordan
peterson's case clean your room
uh or whatever it is or you have to slow
down and you have to
to be present and you have to feel and
that is really the answer to all of this
isn't it
yes and
it's not black and white because the
individual is collective too
it's a false dichotomy it's either me
or the whole because we can only feel
the hole when we feel ourselves
and we are in a field of consciousness
whether we are physically connected or
not
we are impacting each other all the time
so the journey to the individual is
really a collective journey we just
haven't
totally figured it out yet that makes
sense for louise it's been
absolute pleasure speaking with you uh
uh as you know we have one final
question
which is always what's the one thing
we're not talking about as a society
that we really should be yeah we've been
talking about it today without talking
about it because it's
it's a big context of
of where
it's it's it's the ground of all the
conversations we have
which for me is what are we going to do
with
the fact that we are too many people on
this planet
and the numbers are going up and up and
up and up and up
and we get fixated on the stats of kovid
and oh the deaths and that's a bad thing
but if we look at how many people are
born every second on this planet
it's going up and up and up and
very logically that can't continue and
what are we going to do about that
it's such a painful and difficult
question and
we don't know how to even begin
nah don't worry we're going to have a
war and it'll be fine
that's a sad answer i know i know
i'm a comedian i'm supposed to to do
jokes about sad things so i don't have
to address the reality underneath which
is
difficult that's my job uh it's a good
point
it's a very good point it's one we've
discussed on the show in the past and
um you know i i i want to thank you for
coming on
and for giving us this perspective it's
really really valuable i hope
and i'm sure that people have enjoyed it
if
uh our audience want to find out more
about what you do or follow your work
where's the best place to do that it's
my website louisemazanti.com
perfect we'll put that in in the
description of the video uh thank you
once again
for being a guest on the show louise and
thank you for watching at home
and please please please uh follow us on
all the social medias but more
importantly
uh from wednesday right the way through
to saturday 7 p.m or i should say
tuesday right the way through to
saturday
7 p.m uk time check out another
fantastic live stream
or episode and be still present and
notice you're breathing as you're doing
that absolutely don't forget to brief
guys because it gets problematic
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below